for those of you who don't know Obama's
public option has been dropped
congratulations America hey everybody
good news the American people
not only that but those end-of-life
consultations in the bill dropped
completely gone well what you people are
crazy there are no death panels
all right listen drop those from the
bill stepped not only that but for those
of you who've been sending emails to the
White House only to get delivery
failures the flag at whitehouse.gov
email no longer exists
this mitching program is over done gone
disappeared faster than Adam Brody post
OC folks and I tell you this to show you
that what we're doing is working these
are significant victories for the
American people now granted with all of
the czars and the most lopsided
government in history it's very possible
that Obama will try and reword the
public option and ram it through next
week or god knows when which is why we
can't stand down and we need to continue
to fight all of this that being said the
federal government has now realized that
they can't bully the American people
into submission the American people you
did not want this the American people
you stopped this so what I want to hear
from you folks is what these victories
mean to you and how you think we should
move forward from here
what other mediums tools or strategies
can we use to help preserve our
liberties be sure to let me know but for
now we dance
we've a comment